foreign
[Music]
nice place is this the bathroom
this needs to be cleaned
I want you to clean behind the toilet
is that dirty yes when you think of
yourself what do you see garbage oh yes
you weren't anything
I really liked that scene me too it's
gonna be so weird to not have this as
part of my routine anymore
what do you mean
[Music]
you know this job your new role the
company a CEO yeah it's a really big
deal this is not a good idea to keep
doing this
how your new job you wouldn't be able to
do it without what I taught you what do
you want half of the salary of a job
that I got you you're insane it would be
a story CEO shoves cotton swab into own
penis when commanded Denver dominatrix
tells all I mean when you say it like
that makes it sound weird
there's a camera hidden in this hotel
suite I don't want to play right now I'm
not you filmed our session secretly
the [__] camera
if you want to see it so bad then find
it you [__] nut job
what if I if I wanted to I can get rid
of you look at you he loves this are you
excited
take off your pants
you don't have the power I do
what do you want I unlock something in
you now Sanctuary Sanctuary
do you even know why you're doing this
or is this just the game yes
look at me don't look at me sorry